Good morning Hank.
It's Tuesday.
Let me take this gauze out of my mouth.
Oh God.
I just had a pretty invasive oral surgery
down here Hank.
Uh...
This is definitely the highest I've ever been
when making a vlogbrothers video.
My mouth hurts so bad.
Hank, do you know the first time that I reference
this pain that I still have was in my second
vlogbrothers video in 2007.
Hank as you know, I had surgery on my mouth
a few weeks ago.
After they sewed my gum back into my mouth,
my mouth tasted like cement and blood and
burnt meat.
This is the 4th and most dramatic surgery
that I've had and I gotta say that I have
great care.
I have a great oral surgeon.
Great dentist.
So I really am confident that this is finally
going to work.
But ugh chronic pain is just the worst.
The thing about physical pain Hank, is that
it's almost inexpressible.
Like, uh, there's this great book, "The Body
in Pain" by Elaine Scary, that talks about
how like, pain doesn't just defy language,
it kind of destroys language.
Like it's just impossible to use language
to get other people to understand what your
physical pain is like because your physical
pain is always only yours.
But anyway, Hank, this particular surgery
was necessitated because a metal rod had emerged
from out of my gum, erupting from the skin
and pressing against my lip.
That's the best that I can do to use language
to describe how much it hurt.
Hank I'm sorry this video isn't funnier.
Oh, is that- oh it's dried blood.
That's nice.
That's a nice look for today.
But anyway Hank, in the last twenty four hours
I've been thinking a lot about how lucky I
am.
Like I have access to the best oral surgeons
and the best dentists, so you know this suffering
is just necessary.
But there's a lot of suffering that's completely
unnecessary and my favorite thing about the
Nerdfighter community is that we try to do
stuff about that.
So anyway thinking about that let me just
start a fundraiser over at Save the Children
to help them out with their work with Syrian
refugees.
Save the Children is doing amazing work to
get kids in refugee camps access to healthcare
and education and nutrition.
So yeah I started a fundraiser called Nerdfighters
Opposed to Human Suffering Including but not
Limited to John's Post-Operative Pain, which
a Nerdfighter on Tumblr helpfully shortened
to NOHSIbnLtJPOP, or as I like to call it
"No Sea Bin Lieutenant J-Pop."
Nerdfighters I will match all your donations
up to $20,000 and I'm not just saying that
because I'm high, I asked Sarah earlier if
it was O.K. and she said yes.
Hank the only thing I can really say about
pain is that it sucks.
I don't think that it's romantic or transcendent
or any of that.
I think it just sucks.
And I think where we can help alleviate it,
we should.
So donate if you can.
If not to this fundraiser then to another.
And of course it's O.K. if you can't donate
as well.
You've gotta take care of yourself.
Alice needs me to read her an Elmo story so
I gotta go, Hank.
I'll see you on Friday.